14 letters outside Northern Ireland's
Parliament belly seem enough to conveyed
this historic moment for years
campaigners have fought for same-sex
marriage to be legalized and for
abortion in all cases to be allowed and
from midnight they will have won it
marks the end of inequality and
discrimination both for same-sex couples
who have longed wanted to marry the
person they love and also for a women
who have been suffering at the hands of
our abortion ban this change
particularly to the abortion law is
controversial it was brought in by
Westminster MPs and is very mentally
opposed by the Democratic Unionist Party
here but with the power showing
government still not functioning in
Northern Ireland there was no way they
could stop it
it is a very sad day and I know some
people will seek to celebrate it today
and I would say to those people think of
those of us who are sad today and who
believe that this is an affront to human
dignity and to human life but
campaigners did celebrate with wedding
cake and photo opportunities for those
who can now legally marry as for the
abortion laws it still needs to be
worked out exactly what services will be
provided in Northern Ireland and how
they will be provided to but what this
law changes almost immediately is that
women who go abroad for abortions or who
buy abortion pills online as well as the
doctors that give them advice about
seeking an abortion can no longer be
prosecuted and it will mean eventually
an end to stories like Sarah's who had
to go to England for a termination could
be sent away somewhere where we didn't
know and nobody knew in medical history
was a very scary thing unfortunately I
have nuclear to visit my little girl
knew ashes in my home that would be
something that people from Nile will
have the option of having if because we
were able to get the treatment here at
home
last year voters in the Republic of
Ireland chose to end their abortion ban
different polls showed different results
in Northern Ireland it's still a
divisive issue that people often choose
abortions for personal social
convenience reasons and really don't
want to see that happen here I have two
daughters now at one seven one three and
knowing that they will never be in
circumstances where they need an
abortion and can't access this here at
home is a huge relief and the debate
doesn't end here with negotiations to
come over where and how abortion
services will be provided Caterina
vertices Sky News in Belfast